n'observant peric mans que le diplôme
ning fonctionne spectaculairement bien
quand on dispose de quantités massives
de données
il semble que plus on ajoute deux
couches de neurones plus notre réseau de
neurones atteint des performances
stupéfiantes
voilà qui soulève un problème de taille
pourquoi est-ce qu'un nombre de
paramètres égale les réseaux fin est
profond ont-ils des performances
meilleures que les réseaux large et peu
profond d'où vient la déraisonnable
efficacité de la profondeur pour
répondre à cette question certains
chercheurs ont réussi à déterminer des
fonctions spécifiques aux réseaux
profond ainsi certains ont montré qu'il
existait des fonctions calculé par un
réseau profond mais qu'un réseau peu
profonds ne pourra pas calculer à moins
de disposer d'un nombre exponentiel de
neurones et de synapses cependant les
fonctions en question sont très
biscornus et il semble peu probable que
ce soient les fonctions dignes d'intérêt
en pratique en 2016 des chercheurs de
google et stanford ont attaqué le
problème sous un autre angle très
intéressant au lieu de s'intéresser à
certaines fonctions que peuvent calculer
les réseaux profond ils ont cherché à
étudier les fonctions typique que calcul
les réseaux profond autrement dit si je
prends un réseau profond au hasard à
quoi ressemble la fonction que ce réseau
calcul et comment la profondeur
peut-elle modifier les propriétés de
cette fonction ça fait des questions
bien compliqué mais pour les comprendre
on peut se ramener à plier une feuille
de papier alors techniquement les
espaces qui sont manipulés par les
réseaux de neurones sont en fait des
espaces de très grandes dimensions de
dimension 3 cents ou parfois même un
million mais par analogie on peut
illustrer ce qu'il s'y passe avec un
espace de dimension 2 comme une feuille
de papier en particulier dès lors si les
fonctions d'activation des réseaux de
neurones sont des fonctions linéaire par
morceaux comme l'heureux lui dont un
parent est dans l'épisode 41
alors chaque neurone effectué une espèce
de plis une feuille de papier en
particulier une activation relu revient
à prendre une feuille à la plier selon
une direction
une couche de neurones relu la pliera
dans différentes directions et donc si
on a beaucoup de neurones dans une
couche autrement dit si notre réseau est
très large
on aura alors un très grand nombre de
pays et comme vous le voyez ça va créer
pas mal de régions différentes de la fin
on peut alors considérer que la
complexité de la fonction calculé par le
réseau de neurones est en quelque sorte
le nombre de régions ainsi créée est
clairement plus le réseau large plus la
fonction calculé sera composée de
beaucoup de régions différentes
oui mais à quel point le nombre de
régions créé grand dit-il vite combien
de régions sont créées par des pillages
d'une couche 2009 rhône j'avais été
matin parmi vous à mettre pause et à
répondre explicitement à cette question
est bien le premier pli va couper
l'espace puis le second plis va couper
chacun des deux sous espaces créés par
le premier pays il va donc créer deux
nouveaux espaces le troisième plis par
contre lui ne pourra pas couper tous les
sous espaces peu importe comment vous le
mettez il y aura un déçu et ce parce que
le troisième pays ne divisera pas le
troisième clive en fait coupé trois des
quatre sous espace créant ainsi trois
nouveaux sous espace est en fait plus
généralement le énième plis va couper n
sous espace créant ainsi n nouveaux
espaces
alors est ce qu'on est sûr de cela bien
vous pouvez vérifier que c'est le cas en
notant que ce énième plis devra
traverser chacun des haines - un ampli
précédent
chaque traversée d'un pli existant est
un changement de région
c'est même le seul changement de région
possible donc si on suit ce pli on ne
peut donc traverser au plus que n région
le nombre total de sous- région créée
par renggli sera donc égale à 1 + 1 + 2
+ 3 + 4 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à elle
et ça c'est égal à haisnes fois une
pulsion divisé par deux puces 1 comme on
l'a vu dans un épisode sur l'infini
quand on fait beaucoup depuis ce nombre
va bien sûr devenir assez grand on
pourra alors la proximité au premier
ordre par rennes au carré divisé par
deux on dit que le nombre de régions et
quadratique ans le nombre de plis et
quadratique c'est bien mais ce n'est en
fait pas une croissance de folie après
mille plis n'aura un demi million de
région et ça il faut le comparer avec ce
qui se passe lorsque au lieu d'effectuer
lépi en parallèle on effectue des
successions de plis ce qui est
intéressant c'est que faire des
successions de plis
c'est précisément ce que sont les
réseaux profond où chaque couche plis
par dessus les plis de la couche
précédente
autrement dit un réseau profond
correspond à replier un pli déjà fait
puis à l'heureux replier et ainsi de
suite
et quand on déplie tout ça on voit que
cette fois le nombre de régions est en
fait bien plus grand il est en fait
multiplié par deux à chaque repli ce qui
fait qu'après n repli on a deux
puissances n région on dit que le nombre
de régions est exponentielle on la
largeur du réseau et ça ça fait une
grosse différence parce qu'avec 1000
plie le nombre de régions est cette fois
de deux puissances 1000 ce qui est
formidablement plus que le nombre de
particules dans l'univers observable en
particulier ça n'a strictement rien à
voir avec le demi million du réseau
large
en fait ce que les chercheurs de google
et stanford ont démontré en 2016 c'est
que le nombre de régions d'un réseau de
neurones avec activation relu et de
l'ordre de largeur puissance profondeur
mais à mon sens ce n'est pas le plus
intéressant le plus intéressant ce qui
est même très frappant c'est que les
figures qu'on obtient avec une plus
grande profondeur ou du coup ne cessez
de vaciller dans tous les sens et former
des figures stupéfiante pour le
comprendre on peut plier et repliée non
pas une feuille de dimension 2 mai une
espèce de feuilles de dimensions 1
après beaucoup beaucoup de pie et même
plutôt à l'infini on obtient alors une
figure étrange appelé la courbe du
dragon dont michael parle dans cette
vidéo et cette courbe du dragon porte en
fait assez mal son nom car ce n'est pas
vraiment une courbe
c'est plutôt une fractale les réseaux
profond semble avant tout calculer des
fractales
ben on pourrait croire qu'il s'agit là
d'une propriété spécifique aux fonctions
de l'activation relu et bien pour
étudier les réseaux de neurones avec des
fonctions d'activation dit sigmoïde al
ces mêmes chercheurs de google ont
étudié des réseaux de neurones aux
paramètres aléatoires
ils se sont demandés comment ces réseaux
de neurones transformer des figures
assez simple mieux comprendre
je vous rappelle qu'un réseau de
neurones correspondait en fait à une
fonction d'un espace vectoriel vers un
autre espace vectoriel
leur idée est de dessiner un cercle dont
le premier espace vectoriel et de voir
comment ce cercle était bidouillée par
un réseau de neurones à l'aide
ouah en particulier ils se sont
intéressés à une espèce de mesures de
fractal it et de la courbe alors plus
précisément cette mesure consiste à
intégrer la norme des variations du
vecteur tangent unitaire à la courbe
intuitivement plus la courbe gigote dans
tous les sens plus le vecteur tangent
unitaire varie vite et plus la norme de
ces variations est grande et de façon
intéressante
une telle mesure est invariante par
homothétie en particulier la figure
fermé qui minimise cette espèce de frac
qualité d'une courbe fermée et le cercle
qui ne se courbe que pour se refermer
si vous n'avez pas compris ce charabia
mathématiques c'est normal quoi qu'il en
soit les chercheurs ont montré que
pourvu que les pois synaptique des
réseaux de neurones soit suffisamment
agité la fraternité moyenne de l'image
d'un cercle par un réseau de neurones
aléatoire augmenter de façon polynomiale
avec la largeur du réseau mais de façon
exponentielle avec sa profondeur
autrement dit intuitivement les réseaux
de neurones profond semble beaucoup plus
approprié pour calculer des fonctions
quasi fractale et ça ça me laisse très
songeur les fractales ces objets
biscornu que visiblement vous adorez
puisque ma vidéo la plus vue et celles
qui on parle longuement ces objets
auxquels micmac à dédier une de ses
meilleures vidéos
ces objets fantastique dont la plus
incroyable est sans doute la fractales
demande de bruts qu'elle a décrits dans
cette superbe vidéo serait donc
intimement liée à la déraisonnable
efficacité du type learning voilà qui
suggèrent fortement que le figure
fractale sont bien plus omniprésente que
ce que l'on pourrait croire naïvement et
qu'elles sont en fait crucial pour bien
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure
après tout une fois que le concept même
de fractal a été formalisée par wendel
drogue dans les années 70 ou n'a cessé
de les trouver un peu partout de la
bourse aux filaments cosmique de notre
univers en passant par toutes sortes de
processus biologiques de structures
géologiques et de mathématiques des
systèmes dynamiques
les fractales semble partout et il
semble que la profondeur des réseaux de
neurones soit crucial pour les
comprendre
mais toutes ces fractales ce ne sont que
des fractales visualisables or les quasi
fractales que calcul les réseaux de
neurones correspondent à des structures
souvent bien plus abstraite
en fait la réflexion vraiment fascinante
que me suggère le succès des réseaux de
profond et les travaux des chercheurs de
google et stanford
c'est la question suivante est ce que
finalement la bonne sémantique pour bien
parler des images de votre quotidien ou
de notre langage naturel ne corresponde
est elle finalement pas à identifier des
structure fractale par exemple parmi
l'ensemble des images il ya des images
de chats et des images sans chat on peut
donc a priori à peu près séparer les
normes espace vectoriel des images en
deux parties chat est pacha question à
quoi ressemblerait le sous-ensemble des
chats en particulier se pourrait-il que
le sous-ensemble des chats
cette structure géométrique à
l'intérieur d'un espace de dimensions 1
million se pourrait-il qu'il s'agisse
d'une fractales ou du moins de
l'intérieur d'un espace dont la
frontière serait elle une fractale eh
bien j'ai envie de parier que oui il me
semble extrêmement probable que toute
définition satisfaisante de ce qu'est
une image de chats qu à ce monde a
identifié une structure quasi fractales
dans des espaces de très grande
dimension
voilà qui me laisse rêveur
[Musique]
avant de revenir à votre question il n'a
plusieurs parmi vous qui m'ont demandé
où est ce que vous pouvez trouver ces
super casquette la casquette bayésienne
j'ai aussi d'autres une cassette
altruisme efficace que vous avez vues
dans la vidéo de mardi la confiance que
j'ai donnée est aussi des t-shirts qui
correspondent à tous ce prosélytisme
bavaisien absolument scandaleux bain
vous pouvez les retrouver sur une
boutique est ouverte sur le site
spreadshirt donc allé voir si vous
voulez vous habillés de tenues qui font
un peu ostentatoire de cette secte qui
est le gaz à nice mme où la crise
efficace alors sachez que je ne touche
rien des ventes de ce site si j'ai vers
ce site en fait c'est surtout pour
m'acheter moi même ce genre de produits
est également pour permettre à ceux qui
voudraient aussi d'en acheter parce que
je pense que c'est un bon moyen en fait
de faire une action qui est peut-être
finalement une action altruiste efficace
que d'essayer de promouvoir la bonne
façon de réfléchir et bonne façon de
faire des bonnes actions
le gars est assez cool d'avoir un peu au
quotidien des équations aussi importante
et aussi fondamental que les équations
de la forme le buzz ou bien sûr ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut une fois vous avez
porté cette casquette et voir les gens
et leur dire il faut que tu sois beau
dans tout ça
non juste porter la casquette c'est la
1ère fois un moment dans la vidéo j'ai
démontré deux images et vous allez
demander laquelle des deux images a été
créé par un gagnent et d'après vous à
l'image du mec est à l'air beaucoup plus
d'être une image de
fabriquer que l'image de la fille et que
sar axa a vu le troll venir en fait ce
genre de blagues sur des questions je
l'avais déjà posé plusieurs fois en
conférence en avant en scène politique
avec deux autres images et ouais bah
j'aime bien montrer les deux images en
fait qui ont été générés par le gan pour
se dire que bon ben voila si on cherche
à c'est de trouver les failles dans les
images
eh bien on peut les trouver mais si on
ne les cherche pas tant que ça si l'on
montre une image on nous dit même pas
qui a été créé par un gagnent là on
s'est beaucoup plus facile de se faire
avoir
bref il faut aussi travailler notre
esprit critique lorsque l'on voit ce
genre d'image et finalement ça revient à
jouer le rôle d'adversaires dans la
structure de béganne des dettes
génératif anniversario et de façon très
générale en fait l'adversaire des
modèles génératif adverse à riom ça
correspond vraiment une sorte d'esprit
critique qui permet de distinguer ce que
l'on croit avoir compris en testant ce
qu'on croit avoir compris en générant
des données fictives et notre esprit
critique éthique doit être capable de
distinguer notre capacité à imiter notre
capacités d'imitation avec ce qui est
vraiment observer et distinguer le faux
du vrai donc en fait ces structures de
gan c'est quelque chose qui est très
utile d'un produit algorithmique et ça
marche du tonnerre c'est ferran de truc
spectaculaire est sans doute qu'ils
auraient des trucs encore plus
impressionnant dans l'avenir dans
l'année à venir
mais c'est également quelque chose qui
me semble extrêmement utile à intégrer
dans notre propre façon de réfléchir
pour essayer d'être de bien analyser le
monde
il faut toujours avoir nous si possible
un adversaire voire même si possible
même plusieurs adversaires plusieurs
avis qui leur façon de critiquer
l'authenticité de différentes données et
en particulier la capacité que
notre modèle intérieur du monde à à
expliquer les vraies données et sam
hanna aussi un autre point pour que cet
esprit critique fonctionne pour que
l'adversaire et quelque chose à dire il
faut absolument qu'il y ait un modèle
générateur quelque part dans leur tête
c'est à dire quelque chose qui cherche
constamment essayé de faire des
prédictions
essayez de projeter par exemple le futur
a essayé d'imaginer le passé en essayant
de reconstituer le mieux passé et en
confrontant ça avec des bras donné ce
travail de reconstitution de prédiction
c'est quelque chose qui est
indispensable à la structure des gan et
il ya fort à parier que ce soit quelque
chose d'absolument indispensable
également pour l'apprentissage
typiquement si vous voulez devenir bon
en mathématiques il faut absolument
qu'il y ait un système rookie il soit
qu'ils fassent l'effort de générer des
preuves mathématiques rigoureuse
civiquement et il faut aussi que vous
soyez vous même l'adversaire de vos
propres démonstration de proposer en
essayant de trouver les failles dans vos
propre raisonnement
ça c'est quand même le genre de truc que
j'adore avec le machine learning
j'ai rarement avec ses mathématiques
appliquées à l'apprentissage et au
savoir c'est que ça nous apprend souvent
énormément de choses sur nos propres de
façon de fonctionner et notamment ceux
qu'on devrait faire pour mieux réfléchir
est typiquement dans le livre la formule
de savoir que j'ai publié udp science
s'il est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
question de cela pas gagné 75 lui réagi
notamment au fait que dans la vidéo que
j'ai présentée à la semaine dernière
j'ai présenté vraiment la structure de
gamme la plus classique notamment celles
proposées par liane goût de fellow et
ses collaborateurs qui consiste
notamment à juger la performance du
générateur et de l'adversaire à l'aide
de cette divergence kallel de cette
pénalité le gars rythmique de la
probabilité de l'otan cité à signer par
l'adversaire aux différentes données à
la fois réel et aux données générées par
le générateur et pas gagné 75 ans a fait
la remarque que cette approche est pas
forcément la meilleure approche quand
cette mesure de la qualité
d'un fake typiquement n'est pas
forcément la meilleure approche en
particulier
récemment notamment ce qui est licite
trois papiers d'octobre 2018 donc c'est
tout chaud il y a pas mal d'efforts pour
utiliser une autre métriques qui serait
notamment reliées à ce qu'on appelle la
métrique et de wasserstein qui est liée
au problème du transport optimal
problèmes sur lesquels notamment un
certain cédric villani a beaucoup
travaillé et a priori sa médaille fields
a été attribué en partie pour ces
travaux reliés au problème du transport
optimal
alors qu'est ce que ce problème du
transport aux tilleuls en quoi est-ce
que c'est différent d'un divorce qu'elle
en fait le problème des divergences cas
elle sait que vous pouvez avoir une
image quasiment réaliste mais avec un
petit défaut et la divergence cas elle
vous dira bas cette image est pas du
tout réaliste parce que même si elle
ressemble beaucoup
bahia il ya un défaut majeur
intuitivement la métrique vasseur chien
va prendre en compte le fait que la
plupart de l'image est quand même assez
bonne et que du coup il ya un petit
effort seulement à faire pour passer de
l'image générée à la vraie image en
particulier une métrique naturelles ont
l'espace des images si on change
quelques pixels on sent que ça fait pas
une grande différence et la métrique de
vassar chine va essayer de prendre ça en
compte dans sa mesure de la distance en
fin de la similarité entre deux images
alors en fait la métrique wasserstein
s'est encore plus subtil que ça puisque
en fait ces histoires de transport de
distribution
ça sera un petit peu trop mou qui a
expliqué sont ici j'en parle par contre
dans le livre du coup je me lance en
plus il ya un chapitre là dessus après
le truc que je pensais à priori avant de
lire le commentaire de pagan 75
c'est que le problème de cette métrique
de wasserstein était qu'elle était trop
difficile à calculer mais apparemment il
y aurait des variantes de cette métrique
de bathurst high notamment la distance
si chrome qui permettrait d'avoir un peu
cette notion de métriques de serge
taille mais de façon plus calculable qui
se prêterait du coup assez bien aux
réseaux de neurones
celle ci ça ça marche d'un point de vue
algorithmique il me semble que ce sera
une solution qui sera bien meilleure que
la divergence locale puisqu'elle permet
de refléter cette idée très intuitive et
qui semble très pertinente que deux
images qui se ressemblent ne sont
finalement pas si différente et qu'il
faut prendre en compte le fait qu'elle
ne soit pas si différente d'autres
manières de mesurer le degré
d'authenticité d'une image profite
encore plein de recherche à faire est
sans doute plein de trucs trop cool
encore à découvrir
j'espère que j'avais mais cet épisode là
plus loin on va continuer dans notre
exploration des explications théoriques
et du succès empirique du dip learning
de la profondeur plutôt que la largeur
des réseaux de neurones on parlera
notamment d'un article que j'ai coécrit
avec rachid jean-louis un professeur à
l'epfl vous pouvez d'ores et déjà kaki
l'article qui est mort non ici on nous
l'a assez vu
si vous avez aimé cet épisode tant celle
là quelques commentaires et le partage
et pense à vous abonner pour une parodie
et futurs des visages merci au team
powered et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine donc récapitulons si on fait
un pli en obtient elle comme ceux ci
deux plis trois plis on observe ces
figures là et bien entendu on peut
poursuivre ce processus
aussi longtemps qu'on veut si vous le
faites avec top 10 vous pouvez essayer
chez vous où vous obtiendrez cette
figure et puis après allez 5.6 pelisse 7
puis 8 lits 9,6 deeply et ainsi de suite
et vous voyez que plus vous ferez de
pluie plus vous vous rapprocherez d'une
figure limite une figure qui apparaît
comme ceux ci sous nos yeux avec ce
simple petit processus de pliane et
c'est cette figure limites qu'on appelle
la courbe du dragon et c'est toujours
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire de
ces magnifiques et même d' assez
émouvant mathématiques
quand on voit ce genre de phénomène qui
apparaît quand on parle d'une petite
règles de construction toutes simples
comme la juste le pliage d'une bande de
papier et qu'on voit apparaître comme ça
comme par magie une sorte de figure
absolument merveilleuse sous nos yeux
on peut maintenant faire comme tout à
l'heure et coloré en noir les points
c'est pour lequel l'afrique talent de
julia de formule des dockers et pucés et
connexes dernière d'un seul morceau et
en couleurs les autres on obtient alors
ceci on peut voir ça comme une carte des
fractales de julia où chaque point
correspond à un ensemble de julien cet
ensemble porte le nom d'ensemble demandé
le brottes et est pour bien des raisons
là fractales la plus importante des
mathématiques
cette carte des fractales est elle même
une fractale puisqu'elle présente encore
une fois de l'auto similarités même si
cela ne saute pas aux yeux au premier
abord la somme demandée le broad
présente des copies de lui-même un peu
partout